and it takes 20 years 30 years and
everybody says you stink you stink
you're terrible you've spent all that
time
all regret your whole life is defined by
your failure to do this is it still
something you want to do then go do it
because
it should be no other choice in the
matter it takes like an irrational
passion to do it
uh i made a movie with my family's money
and friends money which failed
completely
at 21 made another movie for miramax
that failed completely i mean
no one saw these movies i was done and
the reviews were horrible everything was
terrible
i sold the script to fox they fired me
immediately as a director
i've been on the list as worst directors
of the year so many times and saying
you're done you're done you're done
there was a moment where i no one would
make a movie with me just recently
i don't really think about twists like
that like a dance move or something i
gotta i gotta hit the
that dance move right um it's really
about the characters and
you if plot comes out of characters
it tends to work much better and much
more organically if i'm hesitant at all
about an idea
that's not the right idea or at least i
can't see the angle because
a lot of times it's two things you need
to have the idea and the angle on the
[Music]
idea
when someone comes up to me and says you
know i want to be a filmmaker i want to
be an actor
um you know i'm trying to talk to my
parents what do you think what what
should i do and all this stuff and i
i'm like if there's a choice involved
don't do it
for sure if there's a choice you want to
be an engineer you want to be a dentist
and you're thinking about doing this i
kind of love i love i love
movies i love i want to be a director i
think you know
don't do it don't do it if there's no
other way there's just
no other way i said imagine you've lost
your the person needs you love
you your parents i think you're you're
you're not a failure
you're everything has gone wrong
everything do you still want to be
a and it takes 20 years 30 years and
everybody says you stink you stink
you're terrible you spend all that time
all regret your whole life is defined by
your failure to do this is it still
something you want to do then go do it
because
there should be no other choice in the
matter it takes like an irrational
passion to do it
you can there will be those people that
kind of do the process and then get
lucky
and fall into it but i don't want to
watch movies by those people i
want to watch movies by the people that
there was no other choice
seeing the sixth sense in theaters when
i was 11 was one of the most
mind-blowing formidable unforgettable
theater theatrical experiences of my
entire life and
i was just i've always actually wondered
do you remember
the exact moment that you came up with
that ending do you remember
when and where it came to you that
moment where it just clicked
i i think i do it's blurring a little
bit now but i do
we were my wife was writing something we
were upstairs
and uh we had an apartment and there was
like a little upstairs
room where she had a desk and i was
sitting on the sofa and i was like
huh why why aren't they speaking why is
the couple not speaking
why are they what's the marital problem
what's the marital problem
why aren't they speaking and wait a
minute
it was like that it was like that
because it was literally like that it
came from
character which is what writing in
when it's you know you feel really great
about it that plot comes out of the
character
so the ending came out of yeah i guess
that's out of the plot not like you came
over the ending and then had to figure
out a plot to match it that is oh that's
fantastic
best for me as plot comes out of
character is the best way plot can
happen so for example
one that you've already seen so like you
know in sixth sense it's like he's
working with the boy he's working with
the boy oh i wonder what's this guy's
marriage like well he's not
i just he goes home he doesn't speak to
his wife he just has a difficult time
communicating with his wife
why doesn't he talk to his wife i can
see this character he goes home after
talking and talking children all the
time and he goes home and he can't talk
to his wife
why can't he talk to his wife why can't
he talk to his wife oh my god
you know what happens
and so clock plot comes out of character
right
organic you know very organic coming out
you know you don't have to genetically
change the piece to make it that plot
thing work it came right out of
character you know
yeah you know there's some there's some
really interesting techniques in the
visit that i didn't have a chance to do
before and one of them for example
is no score so there's no score in the
movie um
which is always a it's a it's a
crutch but it's a beautiful crotch and
it's so powerful
music is so powerful it's almost 50 of
the storytelling
and if you take that out then you you
have to the audience doesn't know
whether the scene is funny or scary or
suspenseful
and they have to do more work they have
to and that's what makes it more tiring
for the audience when they listen watch
a movie without
music to be very tight in your
storytelling but it gives you the great
advantage
of they don't that you haven't you
haven't
set expectations in a certain way too
far they
they they're still working it out in
their head i haven't defined anything
yet
you don't know what you're watching yet
if i'm hesitant at all about an idea
um that's not the right idea or at least
i can't see the angle because a lot of
times it's two things you need
to have the idea and the angle on the
idea um so you can have the great idea
you can have the uh
you know the big idea that would have
would have changed the world but you're
coming at it from
there's only one way to come at it where
it's going to explode you know and
you're coming at it from this angle
you know i i learned that a lot like um
you know if the idea for example
from a for unbreakable which when i said
okay the original idea was a plane
crashes everyone dies except one person
who isn't touched at all and then
someone taps him on the shoulder and
says i think you're a real life
superhero i think super you know
that comic book characters are based on
reality and you're
you're one of them that was the original
premise which is a big idea
and i chose the angle on it that was
about
a person who was gray in life a person
who was somber
who didn't know their way and they were
they they just weren't a good father
they weren't a good husband because of
this not doing what they're supposed to
be doing
and through the process of finding out
what they are coming back here
they find um balance and peace now
that's a kind of
that's a kind of dark angle on that that
huge idea that's what i wanted to make
you know that's what how it was going to
be from me and
but i know if someone else made it they
could have done another angle which was
this angle which i
popped into my head as well which was
every kid thinks their dad is superman
this one kid is actually right and that
angle
would have meant four times box office
everybody going crazy
all that stuff i know that that just
wasn't what i was feeling you know and
to some extent you need to have
kind of the idea and the angle that you
can that is you when i got married
we were making a decision about whether
to go to los angeles or not so i could
pursue
filmmaking and uh decided
not to do that for being a
just being a human being it always
scared me los angeles and being there
and philadelphia was so much who i am
and um it ended up being a very
difficult thing because
everyone's over there the 3000 miles
away but in
in in an ironic way it became my
greatest strength because i i was
writing things that were very different
and talking about things that were very
specific to me
and i would drive by a crop circle
because we live in pennsylvania and
and i and and i would write about crops
in a crop circle and
you know in a field and all these
different thoughts that came
uh from being in philadelphia and that
distinct voice and we'll talk about that
a couple of times
gave me great power the more specific i
was actually made me pop from
from the group congratulations uh on the
film i wanna get into
the nitty-gritty of the of the story and
everything but in doing research for
this
night you funded this movie on your own
right you were like i'm just gonna go
make a movie
yeah it was uh you know i had this idea
for this small
weird twisted movie and uh
i just you know wanted to just go just
go make it
and um i don't know you know it was one
of those kind of
confidence in the story kind of things
but also you know trusting in that if
you just concentrate on
characters story and good partners that
everything's going to work out and so we
just kind of went away and shot it i had
no idea we would ever get here where
where we the world would be seeing it
and it was just you know you just go
make
a story you believe in is that a thrill
to be doing that is it more
nerve-wracking
than before i mean what's more
nerve-wracking having someone having the
faith of 200 million dollars in you or
the faith of
this is me this is mine and this is my
family's money and my money
yeah well you you act a little
differently when it's your money i'll
just tell you that right now you know
you work
just a tiny bit harder just a tiny bit
you you
you think about everything just a little
bit more it just means just a little bit
more we gotta pick that light we gotta
beat that light guys but what it does is
makes you very primal as a storyteller
kind of you're you're
you're you're holding to something
that's important to you um
and it does allow you when you're making
a movie at a lower budget at least
in my mind as an artist to do
quicker odd things uh with the movie and
you don't have to be as safe
with what you're doing and in fact
there's when you guys see it there's a
there's a couple scenes in there
[Music]
a couple in particular that just would
never have been made in the studio so
it's just that would have been the first
note
you cannot do that really yeah you
cannot do what you just did
right explain this more or don't do it i
mean just know you just it's too
outrageous you just can't you can't do
this to audiences
and of course that's like the best thing
in the movie now everybody goes insane
when that moment happens and
i mean i used to think that as i got
older and better at screenwriting the
drafts would reduce and i would be kind
of like mozart where i'd be like here it
is
it's finished let's go make the movie
but it's it's not like that
um you know part of the part of the
process
of writing a screenplay is i want to
make a particular movie
uh but the movie does not want to be
that and you have to listen you're in a
relationship with
this movie and this movie is saying to
you i don't want it to be a romance
you know i know you want it to be but i
don't want to be i want it to be about a
father-daughter relationship
and you're going no they they need to
fall in love no
it wants and it keeps on telling you
that but you keep resisting and that
takes a lot of
just like a relationship it takes a lot
of work and so the screen
for me it takes you know 10 drafts
usually around that 10 11 12 drafts
i usually start showing it to people
around the fifth draft
so you know i've worked on it it's not
embarrassing you know it's it's it's
good you get it you know where i'm going
and then we you know the direction that
we need to go on that five percent
that five percent is what it's all about
you know i'm going down this road
just a little bit to the left or the
right makes all the difference
and it's it's all that fine-tuned work
you know you you can see it because you
end up going
um i don't like to the whole second act
i don't get it or
i'm not buying the turn of this
character or something those big broad
stroke things and then as you get to the
later drafts you're going
this line is is bothering me and and you
just start to become
more and more specific you know i think
one of the problems that i have
because i write almost every day is that
i write plays
at this point you know i just write i
you know i force myself now not don't
write a play
because that like as if the screenplay
is the finished
product that everyone's going to read
this screenplay that's how i do it
which is not you know in and then what i
i realize i do i
almost have to adapt this play that i
wrote
for the screen um and it's so it's so
bizarre and i really when i realized
that i said gosh you know because you
can almost take
a bunch of these screenplays change very
little and put them on a stage
which i've thought about by the way and
uh and and
it you know i enjoy that i enjoy the
dialogue i enjoy the the restricted
places and all stuff
but you don't want movies to become
talking heads either so these are the
things that i fight
within myself before i go you know is it
cinematic is it is it finished you know
but there is a moment where you know you
should be able at that point have you
you'll feel the confidence in the
screenplay
and put it up in front of anybody and
they'll go wow you know
i was terrified or i was crying the
whole time or whatever it is that you'll
get that visceral response
as we wrap up i you know i i read
recently that you said that you
envisioned servant as being sort of a
40-part story
which the second i read that my first
thought was like okay so
he's heading somewhere like there's an
ending in the mind do you know
what the ending to servant is yeah
i mean you know there's there's a a goal
of what what is the show about
you know i i think only how many shows
have we gotten to the ending of really
right that we really got to the ending
we went oh that's what the show's about
and we're ki and when it and it betrays
itself that you obviously knew that
people made the show didn't know that
that's what it was about
they came up with an ending at that
moment but it really has nothing to do
with what you saw in season two
i didn't want that i want you to get to
it and feel the resonance
through the 40 of what that close-up of
that footstep
was when she stepped over that threshold
every single thing should make sense and
hopefully
you know as time will be kind to the to
that show
and you could watch all 40 and having
known where it's going and going wow
this is a
beautiful architecture for these
characters that's the hope that it
resonates you know
i mean if we're talking about twists i
mean what do you what do you feel is
is it good twist i mean i don't really
think about twists like
that like a dance move or something i
gotta i gotta hit the that dance move
um it's really about the characters and
you if
plot comes out of characters it tends to
work much better and much more
organically like you're thinking about a
character two people walking through a
forest let's just say
and then you start thinking who are
these two people and where are they
going
immediately there starts to be a kind of
sense of oh they think they're going
there
then they've been walking too long hey
we should have turned already you know
that kind of
now already plots coming out of the
characters and if i could you know we
had more time and we talk about who they
are more and more ideas of plot would
come out of that
i think i wanted to make
feature-length twilight zones you know
where something
you know amazing happens in the last
second and you realize you weren't
watching what you thought you were
watching
and and then inevitably when you go back
and look back at the movie the second
time
everything should should have that
feeling that it was inevitable
that this ending was going to be this
way it's natural these movies have
become so known for their endings and
and i wanted them to be elements of the
movie and not so much
just just just an ending you know just
that's all it is one two hour ending
and i i it's something i struggle with
because i
i basically get an idea and then i
develop it and then an idea turns into
this
wonderful revelation and uh
now i'm i sit down and go well do you
want to do the revelation at the end of
the movie
um and so you know that's something i
guess i'm going to be struggling with
for
for a long time because i may not do the
next movie with that kind of ending
or i may do it the next movie after that
and
been it's been an interesting two movies
here watching everybody
getting you know hearing gasps within
the last five minutes of the movie
i need a lot of information from people
i won't necessarily
follow it but i need the information i
need to kind of hear
how i'm reacting to it if you say i hate
i hate the girl i hate her i hated the
second
she started talking okay you take it in
and you go
what's resonating with that what's
resonating there or you know i thought
he was the biggest punk from the second
you know
i just want i was i wanted him to get
shot you know in that scene and you go
okay you kind of have to little bit let
go of the of the personal stuff of like
you know why is he being such an ass
away he's saying put that away put that
all away but what they're saying is
um they lost touch with the character or
felt
off rails at a certain point you put it
down
and then you you you see what what you
feel as an artist you know
do you i i and a lot of times there's
always some some
some answer that comes from that i often
i
i
often say that there's almost no
criticism that isn't
uh beneficial in terms of uh something
if a studio comes and says
we want you to blow up the village at
the end of the village okay
i'm just making it up sort of and so
they say uh they want you to blow up the
village at the end and all the young
people
run go free and we can have the
helicopters come in and did it and it'll
be visual you go
wow that would be kind of cool um and
then again that other part of me goes
you know what what angle are you doing
on the movie
is that is that you or is that just your
the pot of gold angle and i really wish
that my angle and the pot of gold angle
were the same angle
but a lot of times they're not and i
have to be
responsible i am i know i feel a lot of
responsibility being in this
position and to not always just click
over to the pot of gold angle
you know i i've learned a lot of things
about how
people achieve things you know nowadays
so for example like
um you you can look at my life in two
different ways we can always
you can look at all of your lives and in
any way you want to look at it
emotionally
so one version of my life could be going
he made his first movie at 21.
he's be he sold the six cents at 25 and
became
the highest selling screenplay writer in
in the world
uh his movies have grossed three billion
dollars the last movie became number one
i'm one of three people
in the world that has ever had number
ones in three different decades
everything i've ever written since i was
your age has been made into a movie
and it just seems so easy right that's a
version of my life the other version of
my life
is i made a movie with my family's money
and friends money which failed
completely
at 21 made another movie for miramax
that failed completely
i mean no one saw these movies i was
done
and the reviews were horrible everything
was terrible i sold a script to
fox they fired me immediately as a
director
um i um made a bunch of movies that were
really successful and then i made a
bunch of movies that people didn't like
and i've been consider i've been on the
list as worst directors
of the year so many times and saying
you're done you're done you're done
i made um there was a moment where
i no one would make a movie with me just
recently when no one would make a movie
with me
and i decided to go make and this is
another story we could talk about
where i decided to go make a movie by
myself and and spend my own money and go
for it
and i took a loan against my house
and i and i had an idea and i just went
away and started shooting a movie
i didn't ask anybody's permission and
made it and
i shot the movie and six weeks after i
shot the movie
i got nervous because of my i didn't get
paid obviously i was i didn't get paid
it's been two years
um i took the mortgage on my house and
and as i said the the playing field out
there was against me
and i got nervous and i was like you
know what i just need to make sure that
this is gonna get sold
so i went to los angeles and i showed
the movie only six weeks out so
i just had just shot it just done it to
all the distributors in in hollywood and
we went to theater and i showed it to
him
every single one passed and
came back and i was talking to my agents
and they they basically gave me the
you know i know you worked hard it
didn't work out you didn't you know try
next time
we'll try again kid sorry and you know
maybe we can get some of your money back
i don't know if we can and that kind of
thing so it's over
it's literally this is the feeling right
it's it's over
everyone's against me it's over the
system's against me
i come home i fly back from los angeles
just like numb almost
right and um my daughter is at home and
she's
she had this puzzle and she got this
puzzle and i just said you know let's
just work on the puzzle so i sat down
at the dinner table and said and it's a
thousand piece puzzle we dumped it out
and we started working on the puzzle and
we're i'm like trying to find a piece
just one piece i'm like this is
impossible
this is just i mean i'm literally like
this is impossible
and we're quiet we're just quietly doing
it um
and i found one piece and we put it
there and it took about 15 minutes to
find this one piece
and then i went the reason and something
just went click for me
just emotionally click it went the
reason i'm going to find the next piece
is because i know there is a piece in
this pile
that that fits in here because i know
there's a picture here because the box
tells me there's a picture here
so i'm going to keep working at this and
all i need to do is find the next puzzle
piece
and one day i will have all the pieces
done and the picture will be done and i
went
you know what i don't know how this is
all gonna work out for me
but i'm gonna just find the next piece
and so i went into the editing room and
i just made
one scene better that's it i just sat
down and i said how can i make this one
scene better i was like oh you know what
this is a better take oh you know if i
put this sound effect here that's a
little scary ooh if i come in here and i
made that one scene better and i did
that the next day and the next day
and the next day and the next day and
the next day and the next day
and the next day and suddenly i had this
feeling about the movie and a vision
about the movie and i kept on going and
going until i felt like it was ready and
there was one company
that passed that said i wouldn't mind
seeing it when it's done okay
and so i finished the entire movie and
called them up and said i finished that
movie i want to show it to you i'm going
to show it to you in a movie theater
though
so we i flew out to los angeles and i
showed them the movie in a movie theater
with 500 people who went
bananas and they bought it that day that
movie was the visit which became the
biggest movie independent movie of that
year
and and the ib and i owned it
that's huge and then i owned it
then then then so then after that i i
i paid for split again i mortgaged my
house again
and played paid for split again and then
split went out and became
one of the biggest thrillers of all time
and again i owned it and now i'm doing
the finale of split
and unbreakable which is called glass
which is going to be amazing and i own
that i'm excited for that right
you